[Music]
bart
you have dogs sorry did i scare you
there's a little jarring it's not like a
bark
fart oh yeah okay well speaking of
barking and dogs
uh do your dogs ever warn you or i'm
sorry
dog now it's singular the other two died
well i mean that's why i want to talk
about dogs because he's had a long life
of dogs
you have dogs well you could you can ask
me because i know what it feels like to
have three dogs i know what it feels
like to have one dog
okay well the point is here that i'm
trying to get at is have they ever
warned you for something that they like
trying to protect you from danger
all the time so do you ever listen to
their war like warnings though not
actual like
that yeah my favorite was uh
yeah tyson because he was really good
and you know how much i hate my parents
when my parents come close to the door
they go
because my parents are weird they don't
do the normal [ __ ] where like
ding dong or knock knock knock yeah it's
like i hear rustling in the back of the
house
like they're in the bushes yeah and it's
my dad trying to look through the blinds
what like my like they're like joe was
swimming at my house and you said my dad
just peeked over the wall right
yeah no no he said that he knew i was
there oh yeah so my dad called me and
then he was like oh i didn't want to
come over because joe was over yeah
that's what he said he called me he's
like he's
he's like uh he's like how come he went
home i'm gonna wait what i'm how do you
know he goes i went to your house and
i'm like
uh why didn't you call me and he goes no
i did i mean no i went to your house and
i looked over in the backyard and i joe
swimming in the back dress i thought it
was weird so i left
i'm like well if joe's in the background
i'm probably inside he thought that was
weird yeah so he was
just left he's like he's [ __ ] he has
his friend here swimming in his backyard
that's weird but me creeping around the
[ __ ] the
fence you know what the [ __ ] is doing
swimming in my backyard
yeah so it's like man my parents are
weird and i like i like my dogs because
they
sense and so they let me know and then
it makes me go oh okay cool it's just my
mom back there
your mom like because i remember when
you're trying to hide your ethnicity
from the world
and like even from us like i lived with
him and he wouldn't let me know right
wow
um he was like goodbye i don't know how
to respond to that you just
you just talked spoke to my siri what
the hell that's crazy yeah do not
disturb
it is not do not disturb the moon thing
is on oh weird so
he told his uh parents or his mom not to
tell like where she was coming from
um but his mom walks in and he walks the
other room he goes she comes and gives
me sweets and she goes oh he's
sweet's from taiwan right she runs back
in the other room like okay now i know
what you are
doing and they're they're on the same
like they know the program i'm like
mom this at the time i'm like this is
what we're trying to do we're trying to
pioneer asian american comedy and it's
very hard if asian americans aren't on
the same team
so we want to do all kinds of cultural
humor so we don't ever
and she's like that's good good message
good message good boy
and then immediately this is from taiwan
my son's chinese okay
[Laughter]
god damn it dude wow
i didn't tell him anything so the dogs
so the dogs
back to the dogs so i have a story here
of a pet parrot
that was trying to warn his owner
that someone had had entered their home
so this is what happened
a man entered into their home
through the the unlocked door and he
ended up going up to a wallet
took some credit cards and then just
left oh no wait uh
when the when this man entered the home
he was greeted by the parent with hello
and so that's ty yeah so then
the homeowner just ignored the parrot's
hello
even though that should have been like a
red that's pretty brave
what oh the man the the guy that broke
in
yeah to keep going after parents like oh
you're like
yeah oh [ __ ] you're like way back
am i just securing your friend a
different way because most burglars
aren't
violent or confrontational and they will
leave at the first line of resistance
but but kind of but it's it's so crazy
that we have this animal that can mimic
our like it has the bulk before you do
that but we're so
used to it like have you have you guys
seen annihilation the
olivier wild movie i think or one of
those oh no no natalie apartments
right yeah and they had animals in it
where like when the animals scream you
would hear the screaming of the
person they killed and mimicked the
sound to get the other people to come
out and for us that's crazy but then we
have a [ __ ]
bird that we all keep in our house that
can speak to us but that's because we
saw like two canned salmon cartoons and
stuff you know
yeah but it's like that's why i get
where the guy was like he heard the guy
say hello and
or the bird and he was just like okay
that's nothing crazy like he's super
it's like not
when you really know he's like hey
what's up man if you really think about
that's [ __ ] insane
it is for sure yeah so then as
this man the the intruder as he was
leaving a neighbor
took a photo of them and and then that's
when when they had left that's when the
neighbor called the police
and then police said that the security
cameras did capture the suspect
using the stolen credit card at a local
store and that's how he got arrested but
it wasn't even because of the the owner
even
realizing like wait where's the bird
coming the story when he
said hello when he first entered the
description it was wearing a blue hat
yeah i thought it was gonna be something
like that
the whole thing well pretty much it was
like or the guy here in the other room
the bird say hello to someone like what
the [ __ ] yeah that's pretty much the
the story here is how the homeowner
didn't even realize
someone broke in and the parrot was even
giving him a warning by saying hello to
the because the parrot wouldn't actually
say hello unless
prompted to if like someone came into
the room how do we know that the
parrot said hello i don't know that's
the thing about like why did they bring
up the parrot their home security
they're reporting it as he reported i
did hear my parrot say hello
and i thought it was interesting my
fifth grade one of my closest friends
uh derek he had a parrot and it's really
cool living with one like it's
it's really cool uh from my perspective
when i visit
because like this guy would go like he
had a doberman pincher too
and this it's like a mini doberman so
this guy would barking like shut up
ricky
you just straight tell the doctor shut
up or like derek go to your room
and then randomly he'll like we're like
we're playing we're like doing stuff
we're not supposed to go
like he'll make the exact same noise as
the garage door opening and we're like
oh [ __ ] your mom's back
and then we go we go downstairs and
we're like wait what the [ __ ] and it's
just the bird the whole time that's the
kid
mimic the garage door
yeah that was crazy he does the internet
modem
why i do those birds because they it's
because they copy the jungle noises
and that's why they can they do that all
day at the house yeah like the monkeys
and stuff yeah
yeah cause my mom shut up she had a
parrot too
and his name was primo but like he would
uh every time my mom would yell at my
brothers like primo would be
saying the exact same thing just also
yelling in spanish yeah yelling in
spanish
nobody's saying things like that i don't
know anyone that has a bird anymore
i know that's true i had friends that
had like the background
had bird owning was popular yeah he had
a it was like a big cage in the living
room it was probably the size of this
table
oh [ __ ] and it was like this big and he
was like oh don't stick your fingers and
bite your finger off
the beak was like pretty big yeah is it
because it's like conceptually [ __ ] up
right now
or not right now but like the idea of
like a winged animal
cage it's like different like a dog or
cat running around a house like
domesticated but like a bird who's like
meant to fly
that's true that's true spread their
wings yeah like
when you have pet birds you clip their
wings and they don't fly yeah that's sad
i do remember a time where like maybe
that was like 10 years ago where people
started bringing that up
where it was like that's inhumane
clipping the wings and stuff but
damn because i was about to say i was
like man talking about this makes me
want to own a parrot now
but now that you say this i'm like
apparently not
apparently not i wouldn't want to own a
did you know that
like if you have a parrot and they put
on your shoulder they just [ __ ] all over
your back
because there was a professor at uh that
art center in pasadena
that had a bird on his back and he had a
coat like it was his bird coat and then
when i looked at it it's
covered in [ __ ] well there's a guy in
pasadena that walks with his dog and
the the parrot's on the dog's back oh
[ __ ] is the dog covered in [ __ ]
probably you're [ __ ] nano i remember
petting primo like right in his forehead
like right on the forehead yeah and then
like his whole entire feathers go up it
was so
they're cute it's like they're boners
they never bit me my friend's parents
never bit me or anything like that but
then like
i i heard that they do bite strangers if
you're if they don't warm up to you like
they know they know who's cool and who's
not
it's kind of weird uh when you say so
i'm
naive to this when they used to like
clip
wings what is that i don't know how they
did it uh
disable them they could still like fly
but it'll be from like here to here
like from me to you it wouldn't be like
soar into a tree anymore
it's just like like that wow
yeah i don't know the method though yeah
i don't know the method either they
disable the wheels like the tips i
believe
oh so say you have this this but it's
just the fact it's not like the bone
and the cup like this so it'd be similar
to
uh how you like how people like declaw
cats yeah i think so maybe
oh but the declining cat is like
literally taking out their finger oh
they take the whole thing
out because the thing like comes out
like their fingers can come out
and that's like the clothes it's not a
trim so they literally just break off
the fingers and they're
just the same thing as clipping wings of
them
it's like clipping the tail no i think
it's like that because the the cats
use the things to climb it's part of the
the instinct of a cat to climb and
use those tools to be a cat yeah and
hunter dogs use tails for balance
i think they all use tails for that i
think that's what tails are well i think
also it's like depending on the breed
it's
like say like dobermans they they didn't
only cut them for aesthetic reasons but
back in the day because of the activity
they were doing
with the hunting yeah they need the dogs
to not have those big tails and over
time it's like
for health reasons they kept breaking
and stuff like that so now it's kind of
like
it's not as inhumane to clip like a
doberman's tail but they're not hunting
anymore so it's like okay let it go
they're saying that wing clipping is a
process of trimming a bird's primary
wing feathers
uh so that it's not fully flight capable
until it molts
sheds the cut feathers and grows new
ones so it's not necessarily permanent
it depends on the type of bird
you have to constantly do it and their
personal health and what technique is
used when clipping their wings
so oh like for example some birds such
as parakeets
don't grow their feathers continuously
dang clip it the idea of
clipping something's wings does seem so
right it's it's so like flying as a
concept so like ethereal
right it's so like and it's almost like
a symbol of freedom yeah
yeah there's ways of like training so
like
one thing they do with hawks right like
if you could i learned this on tick tock
um but you learned it under 60 seconds
too yeah uh but
basically yeah but what they do with the
hawks and they train them and it's
basically
you're their source of food right you
teach them how to hunt you teach them
how to do all this stuff and they stay
with you
they could fly away like you literally
let them free to go catch them and they
come back
but they stay with you because they know
oh staying with this human that means
i'm constantly
gonna be fed cause they're they're
hunter hunting animals yeah right
this is what it looks like for someone
oh [ __ ] it looks like this oh just the
feather
like i think the meat is like down here
oh
so i think it's like trimming nails
maybe
if it grows back oh [ __ ] that sucks
yeah well that doesn't hurt um it just
it just kind of [ __ ] them up huh they
can't like use it and [ __ ]
but it's like an animal like that that
needs to fly it's kind of [ __ ] up
it is [ __ ] up because if they stay
like a dog will stay with you you know
like because they're saying like people
that support
the wing clipping or they're saying that
they
they just give wing flapping exercises
to their birds but then people are like
but that's not the same
like what the [ __ ] yeah we're taking the
essence of a bird out yeah
the same exercises but you know be dope
if we could get two eagles and skate on
them in the air
hmm skate on them like like you're
stepping on them yeah
that would be tight huh eagle skiing or
whatever yeah skiing
things or what if you like clip one
bird's wings and then you take those
clippings
and then you like tape them to like a
chicken who can't fly usually
oh [ __ ] and they can't fly on this
opportunity you know so chicken that
finally knows how to fly is that like
when like girls like donate their hair
to somebody else like that sounds like
haircut that means like the birds gotta
walk in willingly like clip my wings for
a lesser bird like an ostrich
you know what i mean oh [ __ ] ostrich
flyers be funny
how scared would that be if there's
ashes naturally in the air
cars in the air even worse though it's
like a bunch of different birds
taped wings oh a frankenstein bird yeah
it did it it's like [ __ ] that's scary
and an ostrich
[ __ ] on your car
they look like dinosaur eggs
hello guys thank you guys so much for
watching all of our videos and i know
it's been a million years in the making
but we finally got
just kidding news merch yup so make sure
you go down to the store below
and you can bring around wow yeah you
can get a piece
of jk news and thank you guys for
supporting thank you
bye-bye
you